madame pilot enseignante et directrice
de ce groupe scolaire
alexandre dumas vient flairer la bonne
ambiance de ces olympiades qui sentent
bon la fin de l'année scolaire
[Musique]
mais c'est tous se retrouvent à la
rentrée
madame pilot elle ne sera plus dans
cette classe qu'elle occupe depuis 28
ans c'est le grand départ celui pour la
retraite
les armoires sont bien rangés prête à la
passation parce qu'il faut un petit peu
de temps et puis je vous avoue que je
n'ai pas envie de me retrouver au mois
de juillet tout seul dans l'école a
arrangé en 28 ans est celle de classe a
évolué les murs ont changé de couleur et
le mobilier s'est modernisé les
souvenirs eux restent inscrits c'est
qu'un seul regret j'aurais dû noter
toutes les bêtises touquet les petites
et blagues les petites choses qui
j'aurais dû les noter comme ça j'aurai
ouvrir j'aurais dû ouvrir un cahier puis
notez tout ça est ce qu'il ya un autre
métier dans lequel fois qui apporte
autant de joie et autant de new way de
bonheur quoi de si je sais pas je suis
pas sûr tu prêt sur ce que les enfants
ils ont une spontanéité une tendresse ou
confiance qu'on perd peut-être en
grandissant ça y est adoré j'ai adoré
faire ce métier madame pilot enseigne au
cm2 une tranche d'âge qu'elle a toujours
conservé
elle est aussi la directrice tout est
prêt pour ma remplaçante ou me remplace
fait même étiqueté tout pour que ce soit
plus simple pour elle j'appréhende un
petit peu parce que je me lance qui
commence à être la retraite mais je suis
prête à partir
et de bons souvenirs alors pour une
directrice qui aura autant marqué
l'histoire de son école impossible de
passer à côté du pot de départ un groupe
de parents d'élèves ces mêmes constitués
en comité d'organisation pour que la
fête soit réussie
près de 300 personnes se sont réunies et
on a il y en a qui sont venus du
périgord lyonnais qu'est venue de
roumanie il a pris l'avion pour revenir
de roumanie
c'est vrai que je vous dise voilà c'est
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'émotion
beaucoup de bonheur beaucoup de bonheur
ouais c'est pas d'émotions plein de
souvenirs qui reviennent et danser une
directrice en or il n'y a pas d'autre
moi c'est vraiment exceptionnel des
discours de nombreux cadeaux une chanson
pour dire au revoir et chapeau à cette
pétillante madame pilot merci
[Applaudissements]